Assalamu
alayikum dear brother Zakir. I am Mahmud
from Toronto, Canada. I am a
post-graduate student of life science.
Muslims today are divided more than ever
before and most of us are being misled
by constant propaganda and false
celebrities who distort Islam but pose
as Muslim scholars. My question to you
is how can we get united Muslim Ummah as
envisioned by our prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. And another
question is are we currently living in
the same situation as the Jahalia days
before our prophet peace be upon him
came or are we comparatively in a better
or a worse of times. I would appreciate
your valuable knowledgeable responses
and guidance for the um jadak.
The two question, question number one is
that we are being led by false
propaganda and false information by
celebrities and many people who pose as
Muslim scholars. And the second question
is that how can we have united um
envisioned by our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. And the
third part of the question is that are
we in the times of Jahalya before
prophet Muhammad are we better or we
worse? As far as the first question is
concerned that I do agree there is a lot
of false propaganda. There is a lot of
pe there are many celebrities opposing
as Muslim scholars and the Muslim um is
divided. Coming to the question of
Muslim scholars of course that reminds
me of the hadith of the beloved
prophetam in which Imam Bkari has
mentioned in his book al- Mufra and Shik
Albbani has classified it as Hassan. He
said that now one of the sabas says that
now is the time where there are many
fukahas and few speakers.
There are very few beggars and there are
many people who want to give charity.
But there will be a time when there will
be very few fukas and many speakers.
There'll be a time where there will be
many beggars and few people who give in
charity. And there are various other
hadith in which the prophet said that
there'll be a time where people who will
not have knowledge will start speaking
about Islam. And I do agree with you
that you know at the time of the prophet
at the Sabbath da' mainly one to one or
when there was a talk people used to
gather few people 10 20 30 40 rarely the
large gathering like etc. And as time
went on, most of the knowledge was spent
either by shooks in the durus or giving
talks in public directly onetoone. And
even in my childhood when I was in
school, when I was in college, I
remember the days that we used to go to
listen to talks of religious speakers or
scholars and at that time maybe in the
'9s etc.
In the late 80s we found that the videos
became popular and besides hearing talks
which became less we used to get
knowledge from the video cassettes or
from audio cassettes or from books of
scholars. So as time passed on besides
one to one dhava the print media
advanced the audio media the video media
but in 2000s you know the social media
came up internet came in the late '90s
and social media Facebook I think 2006
and in the 2000 started and 2010 and now
we are in 2024
and the social media has expanded so
much in the last two decades in the last
20 years phenomenal
and we find that any Tom Dick and Harry
can address the full world on the social
media. There is no expense required. He
takes his mobile phone a smartphone,
records it and uploads it. He may have
few views, he may have hundreds,
thousands or even million views. But to
address to the world has become very
easy because the social media the pros
and cons. There are pros is that okay
you can spread the dean faster. The cons
are that even the fayash and the wrong
things spread faster and even those
people who want to distort the religion
or want to spread wrong things become
easier. So as far as the brother's
question is concerned that now there is
dummah is divided and you have many
celebrities who pose as Muslim scholars
and I do agree with you that now because
of the social media most of the people
unfortunately that come on the social
media they are more targeting how many
viewership they get how many followers
do they get how many subscribers do they
get rather than delivering the message
and unfortunately
This trend has even crept amongst the
Muslim speakers. I'm not talking about
the non-Muslim what they're doing wrong.
But even amongst the Muslim dies or the
Muslim Islamic speakers, most of them, I
wouldn't say all are more bothered about
how many views they gather on the
videos, how many subscribers they have,
how many followers they have on their
social media and what's happening by
this trend. It's happening by the to the
non-Muslim world. or in the other social
media but unfortunately even amongst the
Muslim speakers what's happening is that
instead
of the knowledgeable people guiding the
society the society is guiding the
knowledgeable people. So those people
who come they are more bothered on what
the society likes. So they tailor the
talks according to society not according
to what is required by society. So you
know what when we consult the experts of
social media they say okay if you want
more views I mean you're an Islamic
speaker but you make a video on how to
cook so when you start making a video
how to cook biryani maybe you'll get a
million views and what they're saying is
a fact because you know people like to
know things which are different not only
talk talks so and you may find that the
expert on social media will tell you
okay you play maybe with a cat, you
know, the largest pet amongst humanity
is cat. So if you play with the cat,
you'll get more views. So unfortunately,
not all but many can say most of them
are guided by the society on what they
want. So they're changing their matter
on what is wanted by society rather than
what is required by society. And this
trend is very dangerous. And coming to
your question of Muslim scholars, I
would say that based on the hadith that
the fukkas are very few according to me
today, the scholars are only handful,
maybe hundred or maybe a couple of
hundred, not more than that. Not like
the previous days where there were many
scholars, you know, every country had
mashallah tens and hundreds of scholars.
Now in the full world, if you have to
name, you hardly be be able to name 100
scholar. leave aside more than that and
that's the reason when someone asked me
many years back on this ask Dr. Zak and
I named a few of the scholars. They were
handful and never do I consider myself
to be a scholar. I consider myself to be
a student of knowledge and I consider
myself to be a D. And the role of the D
is that he should acquire knowledge from
the scholars and make it common to the
masses. Acquire the knowledge from the
scholars and make it palatable. Make it
digestible. Make it acceptable for the
um or for the non-Muslims. So the roles
of people like me who are dies we are
not scholars we we don't pose like
scholars and I don't consider myself to
be a scholar I'm a student of knowledge
and I consider myself to be we have to
read the books and hear the videos and
read the articles of the scholars books
of Quran and say and make it more
compatible more palatable and more
digestible for the audience. So my role
is to get the information from the
scholars and make it more acceptable to
the masses. Coming to your second
question that what should be done to to
envision the idea of thought of prophet
wasallam of one um the only way we can
do it is that we should stick to the
Quran and Sunnah. We should stick to
Quran and say. So if the full Muslim
ummah sticks to the Quran and say as
Allah says in the Quran in Alan chapter
number three verse number 103
hold strongly to the rope of Allah and
be not divided. The rope of Allah is the
glorious Quran and the authentic hadith
of the beloved prophet. So if the Muslim
ummah unit unite together and are not
divided only on the basis of the
glorious Quran and on the say hadith we
will be one united um the only way we
can be united is under the banner of the
glorious Quran and say and regarding
your last part of the question that are
we now in the times of jahalyah before
the prophet or are we better are we
worse? Of course the time of the jahalya
before the prophet I would say is worse
than now. We are better than that. But
we are deteriorating the time of the
prophet, the time of the Sahabas, the
practice of the Muslims of the Sabas.
You know after the prophets, after the
ambias, the best generation were the
generation of the Sabas, the companions
of the prophet, the Kulfar Shadin, the
Sabas, they were the best. As the
generation that keep on coming later and
later, we find that we are getting away
and away from the theme. And now we are
more than 1400 years away from the time
of the prophet.
And of course the times have
deteriorated the going more down and
down. But yet I feel we are yet better
than the Jahelia the days before the
prophet. And we pray to Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala that may he give us the
wisdom, the hikmah and the courage and
the patience that all the Muslim ummah
be united. You know the non-Muslims they
are so much against the Muslims. There
is no way that we Muslims can differ. We
should leave aside our small differences
and unite together on the banner of
Quran and say and see to it that when
we deliver the speeches and talks on
Islam, see to it that the message you
give gets a person closer to Allah and
his rasool. see to it that they get
closer to Allah and so that inshallah
all of us we pray to Allah subhana wa
t'ala that all of us all the Muslim um
we will enter Jennif inshallah amen